[Musique]
le nouvel an tamoul a été célébrée ce
jeudi 21 avril dans les jardins de la
villa du département décorée aux
couleurs de l'inde nous avons fêté comme
il se doit l'année 5123 boutade ou vache
to call bonne année à tous les membres
de la communauté tamoule de culture
haïtienne les atouts d un doute parce
que il ya beaucoup de personnes
d'origine indienne à la réunion et ils
forment une partie importante de la
population il nous apporte
une grande part de notre culture
réunionnaise et
ensemble nous cultivons ce vivre
ensemble c'est l'unité dans la diversité
la réunion et cette diversité avec une
part importante de la culture indienne
qui est mise en avant mise à l'honneur
aujourd'hui
le consul général de l'inde a souligné
l'importance de maintenir le lien de
l'inde avec la communauté un doute
il ne s'agit pas seulement de la
relation entre l'inde et la réunion à
chaque endroit où l'on retrouve la
diaspora indienne nous essayons de
préserver cette culture et la promouvoir
peut-être est-ce pas cause de la
distance mais si l'on prend l'exemple de
la réunion cette communauté est présente
depuis 300 ans
certains ont pu oublier leur culture
depuis
mai quand ils réalisent que nous
partageons les mêmes racines avec l'inde
à partir de là nous pouvons développer
ce contact
en tant que consul de l'inde est de
maintenir ce lien entre la communauté
indienne les réunionnais et l'inde
voilà pourquoi les hindous de la réunion
sont importants un jeu de l'inde
ateliers d'arts manuels folklore indien
et danses traditionnelles et modernes
ont ponctué la soirée haute en couleurs
animés par les associations et artistes
ont fait lever sa balle de plans tout
simplement c'est quand même rester chez
on va déjà fait venir c'est à peu près
comme du thé mais n'ont rien à voir en
fait le in et ap
les seuls
shangai clayette dont la sécher va mixer
on va faire
comme une sorte de poudre et à ce moment
là quand on a une poudre qui est
interdite aux voitures il faut
maintenant mélangé avec du citron
quelques petites astuces et plus
essentiel aussi elles généralement la
couture
[Musique]
des toitures femmes
elle a les mains qui sont embellies
c'est une danse rock loric c'est le
caller tom la danse des bâtons on le
fait généralement dans les villages on
appris par des manifestations
culturelles ou cultuelles
et on l'utilisent
quand il ya par exemple
une cérémonie religieuse
en l'honneur d'une divinité
selon la divinité on peut choisir des
selon les baguettes de tambour on peut
choisir une chorégraphie
et on peut le faire soit avec des
bateaux soit avec des feuilles de
village
de marc gosier on en trouve aussi on
peut aussi utiliser des flammes mais ces
briques en général on utilise des
couleurs 27 dans les batailles que cette
année 5123 année blanche avant celle de
l'action soit rempli d'espoir de joie de
bonheur et de santé
[Musique]
à
o o
[Musique]